[Music]
freud's theory of psychosexual
development claims that as we grow up we
pass through
five critical phases
[Music]
our sex drive which freud called the
libido
focuses in a different erogenous zone at
each phase
the phases are called oral anal
phallic latency and genital
if our experience during any of these
phases was traumatic
we might develop fixations later in life
such as neurosis dependencies addictions
or depression the oral phase
age zero to in the first year of our
lives
we discover the world through our oral
senses our main pleasure comes from
sucking our mother's breast or a bottle
the conflict that occurs now is the
weaning from our primary caregiver
hans is weaned off his mother's breast
without trauma
ernst's mother stops feeding him within
four months of birth
which is too early eda is often left
alone
crying when she is hungry
hans becomes a healthy and independent
adult
ernst suffers from trauma and develops
an oral fixation
he tries to compensate for it by chewing
gum all the time
eda spends her entire life looking for
the oral stimulation she was denied as
an
infant and therefore develops a
manipulative and addictive personality
the anal phase age one to three
the primary focus of our libido at this
age is the control of the bladder and
bowel movements
we have to learn how to use the potty
han's parents
praise his attempts to use the toilet
and encourage him to learn at his own
pace
ernst's parents force potty training on
him too early
and punish him for mistakes edi's
parents neglect
any efforts at potty training entirely
[Music]
hans develops a competent personality
and a good and balanced relationship
with authority
ernst develops an anal retentive
personality
he becomes an over-controlling and
stingy adult
with disgust for his own body and a
tendency to obey authority
eda develops an anal expulsive
personality
she becomes messy disorganized
inconsiderate of other people's feelings
and rebellious against authority
the phallic phase age three to six
our libido now turns to the genitals as
we discover the differences between the
female and the male
gender the boy's conflict in this phase
occurs as a rivalry with their father
also called the oedipus complex ernst
and hands desire to possess their mother
and fantasize about getting rid of their
father
but they know that their father is
stronger and fear being
punished for their desire freud called
this
castration anxiety eda experiences
penis envy she believes that a penis is
the key to power and domination
and also wants one
han's father was very present during
that phase
later hans resolves this conflict by
identifying strongly with him
he learns to take on a male role as an
adult he respects both genders ernst
whose father was absent during that
phase fails to develop a strong sense of
manhood
he has a mother fixation and is not sure
about his sexuality
he also tends to be aggressive towards
women and
constantly needs to compete with other
men eda
like all women maintains her penis envy
for the rest of her life
which in her case causes an inferiority
complex towards men
[Music]
layton phase aged 7-13
in this phase our libido is suppressed
as our sexual energy is being sublimed
into developing
life skills our super ego strengthens
and we strongly identify with social
values
same-sex heroes and friends
hans follows many hobbies ernst loves
learning at school
and eda makes lots of new girlfriends
[Music]
there is no real conflict in this phase
all three of them benefit for the rest
of their lives from the skills they
developed
during latency
the genital phase puberty to death
once we reach puberty our libido starts
to become
active again and we develop an interest
in sexual partners
hans eder and ernst face the challenge
of balancing the sexual desires of the
id
and the needs of the super ego to obey
social norms
the development of a strong ego helps to
find a compromise between the two
hans who has experienced a childhood
without much trauma
succeeds in building a strong ego he is
disciplined at work
has a loving relationship and a
fulfilled sex
life ernst's ego is weaker than his
superego
he obeys norms and authorities and as a
result
suppresses his desires which leads to
the development of perversions
eda has a weak ego and a weak superego
her sexual needs are more important than
social norms or other people's feelings
she is egoistic and feels no guilt for
breaking the law or hurting others
to understand the theory we need to see
it in the context of
freud's famous work on the unconscious
by acknowledging that we have a
subconscious
he also implied that we store memories
of early childhood
and other experiences without even
realizing it
these past experiences then
unconsciously influence our behavior on
a daily basis
freud claimed that our mind operates in
three spheres
which we can imagine as a submarine the
unconscious
level operates the id
the pre-conscious level operates the
super-ego
the conscious and pre-conscious levels
operate our ego
young children are driven by the id and
demand immediate satisfaction
at around age 7 we begin to develop a
super
ego and want to become good moral
citizens and please
others the ego is formed with
adolescence
to balance the two forces
[Music]
sigmund [ __ ] freud was an austrian
neurologist and the founder of
psychoanalysis freud theorized that the
unconscious would remember and store
all our experiences later they pop up
from time to time
through dreams and associative thoughts
by revealing traumatic memories and
desires through conversation
we can free ourselves from our neuroses
and live a more healthy and fulfilled
life he recommended we should not strive
to eliminate our complexes
but to get into accord with them they
are legitimately what directs
our conduct in the world
what do you think about this theory and
the practice of psychoanalysis
is there some truth in it do we have an
unconscious
if so does it really store all our
childhood experiences
and influence our behavior as adults
please share your thoughts in the
comments below
sprouts videos are published under the
creative commons license
that means our videos are free and
anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools
governments and non-profit organizations
can also use them for training
online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute
just visit patreon.com sprouts even one
dollar can make a difference
if you have deep insights into academic
topics and want to help us
explain complicated ideas in simple
language please contact
us at sproutschools.com
you